welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and the loki finale left us feeling
kind of like confused little kids
oh grow up all credit goes to the
cryptic performance of jonathan majors
as he who remains a variant of kang the
conqueror and we know he
won or a version of him one but how
exactly eating an apple all day to keep
doctor strange away
after obsessing over this final episode
i have realized that uncertainty and
distrust
are necessary components of he who
remains planned
a plan that he actually started to show
us a script of we have
part of a plan but when we step back and
start to widen our scope and realize
that this plan was truly kang's plan
we can better understand where things
are headed not only in season 2 but
most other mcu titles ahead really the
first question we have to address is
is he who remains working against his
other variants or
actually working in their collective
interest he explained his original
variant was a 31st century scientist who
discovered multiple realities at the
same time as other variants
leading to a period of knowledge sharing
but then multiversal war that war
created tears in reality that created
eliath which
this variant weaponized creating the tva
and the void to prune the multiverse
down to one timeline in the chaos and
stop the war
we can conclude then that the nexus
events the tba has been pruning are
branches that
actually lead to the rise of kangs he
who remains says what he fears most of
all
is himself and describes his role as a
safeguard against the other kangs i
keep you safe and if you think i'm
evil just wait until you meet my
variants but the confusion comes from he
who remains
apparent delight upon their crossing the
threshold going off script the sacred
timeline unraveling to allow other kangs
through the floodgates and sylvie
killing him
it's as if he wanted this to happen as i
pointed out the breakdown he remains
might have called this shot back when
sylvie beheaded the timekeeper in
episode four
and we just learned from the director
that all those timekeepers were voiced
by jonathan magers but despite
all of he remains hard work why would he
now want his sacred timeline to
unravel and other worst kangs to take
over he made it sound like that was the
worst option with his preference being
that
loki and silvi replace him willy wonka
style there's two
options one kill me and destroy all this
and you don't just have wine devil you
have an
infinite amount or
you two you two run the thing when loki
asks
why he would give up his power he
remains responds
i'm tired and i'm older than i look
this game is for the young
the hungry now i think he remains might
be telling the truth when he says he's
old and tired but i think his true
intended replacement is a younger and
hungrier kang
he who remains plan and kang's plan are
one in the same to preserve
kang's supremacy by turning loki and
sylvie
against each other and thank you to
vessi shoes for sponsoring this video
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and snow proof making
in the perfect travel shoe these bad
boys are made for splash mountain which
growing up in florida is what we call a
trash mound after hurricane because we
couldn't afford to go to them
fancy theme parks that sea shoes are
super
stretchy they fit like a sock they only
weigh 175 grams which is great for
throwing in a suitcase
they're made with this dimetex material
that keeps your feet warm in cold
weather but cool in warm weather
and it's super easy to clean with just a
rinse of water these are truly an
everyday
shoe whether you're hitting up a theme
park hiking through a national park or
just getting a drink spilled onto you by
randall park
keep the close-up magic out of the bar
jimmy whoo
skip in through that grass swallow them
drink them oh
no i spilled water all over my feetsy
weezies but my oinky oinkies are bone
dry
like the dune see thanks bessie
so get them while they still have sizes
and you can thank me later check them
out in the link below and use my code
new rockstars to get 25
off your vessy shoes from the tba's
perspective the most significant anomaly
on this series occurred back in episode
when loki and sylvie held hands creating
a nexus event so dangerous it bypassed
the apocalypse that was supposed to
erase it
you ever seen a branch like that no
therefore the greatest threat to kang's
order is
two gods of mischief combining their
intellects that
crashes the system an anomaly so rare
so unprecedented that the first words we
hear he remains speak
reflect his shock at seeing two loki's
together this is wild
the two of you same person i mean
it's a little unnatural but wow
and when they later cross the threshold
the thunder rumbles the sacred timeline
begins to unravel
sylvie has not yet even killed he
remains though
that timeline is collapsing on its own
and that's because the moment variants
l113
and l1190 came together the version of
the sacred timeline that's been overseen
by he who remains
became obsolete and was destined to
unravel the longer these two variants
stayed together and now he who remains
has accepted his fate that his fragile
stalemate can no longer function and as
much as he hates to admit it he must
save his kang empire by stepping down
and while doing so making sure these two
loki's are
divided now in the comics the variant
kangs are organized into a council of
kangs led by kang
prime they eliminate divergent kangs
from the multiverse to ensure kang prime
would become immortus
a confusing couple sentences there i get
it but the point is he who remains is
likely not working alone but
really on behalf of the greater kang
kind and now
thanks to his system failure to ensure
the survival of the kang empire he must
step aside and allow
a new kang to take his place if you
think about it that way it starts to
make sense why he remains presents his
gambit this way
[Music]
that's the gambit stifling order or
cataclysmic chaos kang's gambit is
perfectly designed to turn loki and
sylvie against each other by giving
one exactly what they want while giving
the other what they most dread
plain on their innate propensity to
distressed to outsmart to overthink or
as mobius says
it's always the game within the game
with you guys so in this ultimatum we
got option a
perpetuate the lie allow loki to rule
alongside his love but in doing so
trap sylvie alongside someone she can't
fully trust
and force her to rob countless innocents
of their free will
as was done to her as a young girl like
even if silvia had said yes to this
eventually it would have worn her down
and turned her against loki so instead
she cannot help but go with option b
revenge executing he who remains for the
injustices that she's experienced even
if that would mean plain kang
whack-a-mole for the rest of all time
because think about invention seekers
they always just keep scratching that
itch it's never enough and in doing so
this would forever trap
loki within someone else's game which is
his worst nightmare so knowing all the
loki's tendency to second guess
everything is their own undoing he
remains primed this ultimatum with seeds
of doubt the entire conversation
my methods are
deceptive sylvie you think you can trust
this guy
we're all villains here we've all done
horrible terrible horrific things
which notice he says to sylvie while
pointing too loki so as it comes time to
make a decision whichever option they
might lean toward he who remains this
already riggs this decision by priming
these loki's to doubt each other they
now believe
either option is a zero-sum game where
if their variant were to win they were
to lose it's game theory 101 folks play
your opponents against each other by
making them think cooperation is not an
option
because you can't trust
and i can't be trusted so when the
timeline begins to fracture before
sylvie even makes a move and they go off
script he who remains knows
in that moment that his plan was
successful it's proof that the script is
no longer in his hands but in the hands
of one of his variants
and more importantly that sylvie and
loki are no longer on the same
page of it divided and conquered and
that is where loki is tragically left at
the end of this season
just as lady sif said he would be i hope
you know you deserve to be alone and you
always will be
but the fact that he could just want
someone else to be okay
learn it's not about him that gives us
hope that he can defy the master plan of
team kang
and knowing this we now know what kang's
fear the most are not
other kangs it's other nexus beings that
could destabilize their empire
and variants of the same being
cooperating complementing each other but
not following the history that the kang
variants did and going to war with each
other
so kang's greatest threat going forward
the scarlet witch
alternate sorcerer's supreme a possible
trio of spider-man variants
and loki's someday hopefully learning to
trust each other comment down below with
your thoughts and theories
remember you can still get our loki
inspired merch at newrockstarsmerch.com
like our loki at a time shirt directly
supports us here at new rockstars follow
me on instagram and twitter
eaboss follow and subscribe to new
rockstars thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you